I call it my morning formula although
ironically I only ever read it in the
afternoon when I have my afternoon break
but literally I have a list of like 100
truths both future ones and pre-existing
ones I know are true about me whenever I
have that moment of self-doubt I go back
to that and I look at the Legacy which I
built up and I look at in my makeup my
identity everything and it makes me feel
good am I more or less likely to do
stuff when I feel good you're going to
see those challenges that you might see
as challenges they're going to be just
you're just going to have taken the edge
off it by just giving yourself a little
boost of self-confidence and self-worth
because these things are true can't be
taken away from you and that often just
helps people just to get started with
doing something the other thing as well
is even if you have a go at those things
nobody can ever take those truths away
from me because you've already got them